to the fans who discovered us during the
Machine Gun Kelly episode to the fans
that were there when the key & peele
episode dropped this one is for you
shout-out to my day one the hot ones
fans who have been there from the
beginning this one's for you
looks like the hot ones editor Chris
Murphy how do you think called we're
going to handle sauces in a live to tape
setting I actually think he's going to
get kind of crabby I think he's going to
snap a little bit pushing you where yeah
I do like the idea of the full body
hoodie 3 boom I'm good I'm good I feel
ready I'm excited I'd be lying if I said
I wasn't pitting out a little bit in
here I kind of need a deodorant re-up
for sure
[Applause]
right so we're at the leaf show as you
can see enormous wraparound line they're
like we have to see those wings we have
to see Stephen Colbert death death sauce
I think that's what everyone here is
excited for Jeff so we're doing
extensions a is the whole deal yeah I
want these lips to pop okay how about
that
[Music]
I think Stephen was lulled into a false
sense of security and then dabomb who
popped him and then steps off dead man
walking and then we just run it around
the stage working cameras and stuff and
I was just like thank God I didn't throw
up or pass out you know